i was watching an interview between
stephen colbert
and barack obama that just shows you if
joe biden ascends to the presidency
what we are going to be in for watching
the news over the next four years or
however long biden would be in office
president obama thank you so much uh for
joining me today it is wonderful to be
here thank you for having me yeah it's
good to see you
i it is good it is good to be seen i've
been seeing you on television but it's
good to see you in person
that's nice and uh that's kind of a demo
in some how old are you
are you are you here are you 18 and 54.
i'm not the demographic you're looking
for sorry it's too late i apologize
doesn't count michelle says hey oh good
yeah good you know
you know she loves you well i've i've
really enjoyed spending some time with
her over the last four years
i know yeah and and she she's she she
adores you
she thinks the world baby i think you're
okay
can we just just take a moment can i
just i don't i want to talk i just i
just want to take a moment to
to to drink you in for just a moment
because
i'm having to get used to looking at a
president
[Laughter]
again you know i've gotten out of i've
gotten out of the habit you got
i got to warm up for joe biden i don't
want to pull anything when i see him
take the oath of office
you got to ease me into this a little
bit i
have never heard a more flirtatious
conversation than this bizarre
little intimate powwow between stephen
colbert and barack obama i feel
like a voyeur watching this this
conversation
i feel like i'm peeking in on two high
school teenagers
you know about to play spin the bottle
or something this is so
revolting how much colbert and the media
fawn over barack obama and i it
it's giving me flashbacks to 2008 to
2016
when when chris matthews was getting a
thrill up his leg
seeing barack obama when the the
question
there's one question from a white house
reporter they were doing a really
in-depth hard interview and
they said uh mr president mr president
obama what has enchanted you
about the white house what is what has
enchanted you about this job wow hard
hitting stuff guys
you can't trust the media obviously
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you